estaría preguntándole Qué posibilidades
hay de que la elección se decida en
primera vuelta a estas alturas de qué
depende
Buenas tardes
bueno Lula tiene reales posibilidades de
ganar en una primera vuelta según las
principales encuestas de opinión todas
las más recientes le han dado una
victoria en primera vuelta de Lula
históricamente tenemos siempre un 20% de
abstenciones de gente que no va a votar
y de esos 20% la gran mayoría es de
izquierdas así que bueno
tenemos que ver si la gente si a esa
gente va o no va a votar porque puede
ser que si la gente que se abstiene sean
votos que Lula va a perder y con eso
Puede que haya una segunda vuelta y como
lo comentaba se habla mucho de la
extensión pero también del voto
evangélico en Brasil Cómo se ha
distribuido Cómo se ha movilizado este
voto en esta campaña
el fotos evangélico Elba casi
enteramente a bolsonado fue el voto
evangélico fue fundamental para que se
eligiera en 2018
los pastores en los púlpitos en las
iglesias evangélicas todos hicieron
campaña para bolsonaro y bueno esa es
como la parte de la electorado que es
muy fiel a bolsonaro es una electoral
que difícilmente cambiaría su voto sin
embargo
en un panadero más general
en estas elecciones son una minoría
frente a los que decidieron votar por
Lula y precisamente hablando del actual
presidente Yair bolsonaro realmente se
contempla que no llegue a reconocer los
resultados electorales si pierde
es posible porque en la mayoría de los
países los que cuenta estas los
resultados son los que perdieron las
elecciones sin embargo en 2018 bolsonaro
ganó las elecciones y aún si
contestó los resultados de la elección
de las elecciones y durante esos cuatro
años y este año que es un año electoral
todavía más sigue acusando el proceso
electoral brasileño de no confiables las
urnas electrónicas y aquí las urnas son
electrónicas también Deja que hables de
no confiables entonces en eso se centra
su discurso incluso todavía no ha
mostrado como un programa de gobierno su
discurso se basa básicamente decir que
que es mentira que es corrupto y que las
elecciones no son confiables y a lo
largo de los últimos meses hemos visto
como la diferencia entre Lula y
bolsonaro se ampliaba y se recortaba de
Cara a una segunda vuelta eventualmente
que escenario enfrentaríamos
en una segunda vuelta probablemente
también ganaría Lula el tercer candidato
como más intenciones de votos que tiene
un 7% de votos que sería Ciro Gómez es
un candidato de centros izquierda
entonces mucho de sus electores
terminarían contando por Lula
quizás muchos de los lectores de los
demás candidatos también
y Bueno creo que Lula todavía gana Así
si aún hace una vuelta